Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning now.
It isn't.
Oh God dammit.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast
and um,
dre,
big of checking in on you.
Just like the Frat Gold Cantar.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
Do they have Christmas music and other countries?
Is it strictly in American thing?
I can't imagine.
You're in England and they give a shit
about bing Crosby go on where the trees are glistening and chill.
Dread lists
too.
They don't even have like enough fields over there for sleigh bells to go
through.
Right.
There's no fucking room over there in England.
It's all been developed.
That's why we ended up coming over here.
Was it because of religious differences?
There was too much urban sprawl over the AA.
Even back in the 16 hundreds.
Yeah.
That's why people's teeth in England is so God damn crooked.
It's not because they don't take care of the teeth are all mashed together.
I'm sorry.
I had no intention of getting on this podcast and insulting,
um,
the great state of England.
You know,
there's a lot of great states out there,
right?
Rhode Island,
Connecticut in England,
England is an incredible state.
It's about the size of New Jersey.
You've got to admit,
man,
for such a small country,
they,
you know,
it definitely,
definitely let themselves be known around the world for better or for worse,
depending on what side are the queen you're sitting on.
MMM.
Why would I,
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
You know,
I don't give a shit because technically I'm on vacation.
Okay.
Um,
I don't even feel that.
I don't even feel like I need to be making an effort at this point.
Um,
who knows.
I'll probably lose another fucking advertising.
We're trying to sell a,
we're trying to sell pencils over and you'd the United Kingdom,
but we just felt some of your,
some of your statements to just went beyond comedy and just can't get into a
area that we didn't feel was inclusive.
Okay.
Those people,
everything's a question.
They're like literally taking the piss out of you and say,
you know,
I just felt like you're not,
we just feel like you're not doing the job we need to be done.
That needs to be done
and that you're going to be unemployed during the holidays.
That would be best for [inaudible].
Okay.
The ultimate passive aggressiveness is you walk around and you don't have the
common decency just to just be standing there flat footed,
be the client that you are.
Instead you do everything with questions.
So that's when I stole your password for your bank account
and depleted all your savings.
So I'm sorry,
I'm writing this from the Cayman Islands.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm back.
I'm back in Boston baby.
A lot of bees there.
Literally Shawn,
the racial past blue ribbon number,
Cajun man.
Adam Sandler weekend update back in the day when I was young.
Um,
I'm back here in Boston and uh,
this is my first Christmas as a dad.
It's pretty exciting.
I,
uh,
made a promise to myself that I was not going to flip out
and all that.
I was just going to be,
I was going to be as rosy as my daughter's cheeks are right now because she's
teething.
And I was able to do that until I picked up the rental car.
I lost my shit twice,
maybe three times.
I vaguely remember taking my hat off and throwing it as hard as I can down at
the empty passenger's seat,
you know,
like it was the end of the game and there was a terrible call.
Like somebody scored a touchdown and they said,
oh wait,
you didn't make a football move and now I've gotta be on the road during the
playoffs.
Play off.
All right,
here's what happened.
Um,
we had a very early flight and,
uh,
and this is the first time I was flying.
No,
no second time.
Second time flying with my wife and daughter.
But the first time we did my Kiddo was so young,
you know what I mean?
It was like bringing a loaf of bread with you,
you know,
she was really into being held back then snuggled in,
all that type of stuff.
Well,
now my kids mobile go in mode.
Wow.
All right.
I believe she's what they call cruising at this point,
which means she can pull herself up on a table and then walk side decided to
like all kinds of stuff like that.
Although yesterday she actually let go over table,
turned around and then reached for something else.
Now she's never done that before.
What she would do,
it'd be like,
wow,
that's way over there.
I'm not going to go down,
sit on my butt,
crawl half a step,
and then pull myself back up again.
This is the first time,
you know,
she did sort of a wrestling move,
like coming off the rope,
spinning around.
She did everything but a flying kick.
So my days are numbered as far as
you know,
being able to stick her in a general area and turning my back and expecting her
to still be there.
Um,
so now,
yeah,
she wants to move around.
I gotta tell you something.
She was an absolute angel on the plane.
Oh wait.
Am I hearing other shit here?
Ready?
What in the fuck has that been going on?
The whole podcast?
Sorry,
I had my headphones on.
What?
Fucking advertiser.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
I was on Google plus.
Well,
I'm sorry for the Guy Mumbling in the background,
but it wasn't some crazy relative.
Yeah.
This is some old guy talking about how the US and the Chai Cheney,
China need to communicate.
Oh,
is that what we need to do?
Why don't we all just fucking leave each other alone?
How about that?
How about we stay over here?
You stay over there.
You shoot your missiles at yourself.
We'll fucking throw shit ourselves if we feel like we want to kill somebody.
Why don't we just do it?
Why does it everybody in the world just grow the Fuck Up,
Huh?
All of this bullshit about fucking going to war and all of that crap.
It's just a bunch of rich people at the top throwing temper tantrums because
they want some sort of oil or they want some sort of land.
They want some sort of water outlet or they don't feel that you're praying to
the right fucking person or they don't like your form of government.
Who gives a fuck?
You know?
You'd think I like all of my neighbors.
I don't dislike any of my neighbors.
But you know,
in the past
I haven't liked my neighbor's music.
I,
when I lived in New York,
I didn't like the smell of their food.
I didn't like listening to them arguing or fucking or whatever.
You know what you do in New York City.
But did I ever go,
did I go on the fucking warpath
did I?
Did I fucking,
you know,
suck a punch somebody as they came walking out of the apartment though,
I didn't.
You know why?
Because I'm a fucking adult.
All right.
And I think they get tagged time that Democrats or Republicans,
the Pentagon and everyone ran a whole bucket.
Just grow up.
Just fucking grow up already.
Yeah.
I gotta be honest.
You,
I cannot believe that war is still illegal.
The risk of sounding like a fucking tree hugger.
I can't believe that it's a,
a,
it's still legal.
You know what this is.
This is my simple theory that I worked out by myself,
so there was no one there to argue with me,
so it completely makes sense.
I definitely believe that you have to be a little sick to want to lead a nation.
Um,
so
I think that yeah.
Got a lot of fucking complete lunatics in power and they,
they make those choices like a,
like what's his face,
Martin Sheen in the dead zone.
The birds in a way.
Yeah.
Gentlemen,
the birds are away,
right.
That's kind of how I look at,
uh,
most of these fucking people that run corporations and all of type of shit.
MMM.
And I dunno what happened.
This all just got depressing,
which is why I don't watch the fucking news.
I feel there's plenty of water.
There's plenty of food.
There's plenty of room for everybody.
If everybody would just fucking relax,
you know,
and quick peek and over your fence to see what other people have and just be
happy with what the fuck you have.
We can have a nice Jane farmer's market every Sunday.
Okay.
Oh,
you got a barrel oil?
Oh yeah,
we,
we got a box of snickers bars.
How about that?
We'll do a little fucking change here.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm flying on the Goddamn five.
I'm sorry for the fucking audio.
I don't have time to change that shit.
I apologize for the Guy Mumbling in the background.
MMM.
It's soda.
My,
my tribute to dark side of the moon.
You know,
that guy's mumbling.
All that shit.
There really is no dark side of the moon.
It's all dark.
MMM.
So we did great on the plane.
Everybody was loving my daughter over there.
She was just peeking over the seats,
waving at everybody.
Flight attendants were carrying her,
walking up and down the aisle.
It was great.
Um,
by the end,
she had everybody loving or just smiling and waving.
I'm going to try that on a flight.
I'm going to start peaking over the seat,
just smiling and waving at people like fucking lunatic.
Oh my gosh.
I was a fucking song is in my head.
I know our daughter has this little little car that when you fucking turn it on,
how's it [inaudible] and I love driving on the road to,
to be,
be grabbing all the way around the town,
waving to all I need smiling,
waving B,
B
over and over again.
So anyways,
I did great.
On the flight by,
yeah.
You know,
I made a promise that I wasn't going to flip out this whole,
this whole trip.
Wow.
I would say I was able to do it until the rental car.
Right.
All right.
We're going to eat.
Okay.
Text me when you're done.
Just stay here working during my vacation.
Thanks for coming in and helping out.
Definitely when you're done.
Okay.
MMM [inaudible]
so anyways,
I,
we go to get off the plane and it's the usual battle between a man and a woman.
The guy's thinking,
okay,
we checked bags.
We also have to pick up a rental car.
Yeah.
This is going to be all these fucking people there.
All right.
It's going to be a bunch of people traveling is going to take forever to get the
bags.
Why don't I,
while you guys wait to get the bags,
I'll get on the fucking bus,
the rental car bus and I will go over
to pick up the fucking rental car.
You know?
And my
wife is a Homerun,
right?
Always was a woman by the way.
She did not transition just to be progressive.
And give all you the information.
MMM.
She's a hormone.
So she wants to be social.
Oh,
I thought we can all go there together.
Why?
No,
this is me.
I'm a tell you right now.
I though we could all go there together.
She just gave me the finger.
Uh,
and I'm like,
honey,
we have three check bags.
I didn't want to check a bag.
I was going to travel.
Oh good.
My kids,
kids screaming in there.
Um,
I didn't want to check a bag.
I was just going to pack like I was going to go do a funny bone or some shit.
Right.
Couple pairs of pants,
a couple of headliners,
shirts,
sweatpants and a t shirt.
Right.
But she's just saying,
what if,
what if we go out to eat?
What if we get some Christmas kids too?
We need space.
Could you just please?
Very good giant bag.
So I took out my fucking bag that,
you know,
I didn't even use the last time I went to Europe because I finally learned how
to fucking pack.
So we had three of those fucking things.
So I'm like,
honey,
we're going to get off the plane first cause we're riding up front like fancy
people.
We're going to stand down there for a good 1520 minutes while the rest of the
people filed down.
And then we'll stand there for another five minutes before the belt turns on.
And then after the belt turns on and everybody's excited,
it's just going to shut off.
And then everybody's going to be like,
what the fuck?
And then another belt,
two belts over,
it's going to turn on.
Okay.
And some smarty pants is going to figure out that that's actually where our
flight is,
except he's not going to tell anybody cause he's a selfish cunt and he's going
to stand over there.
And then gradually people will start noticing faces from their flight,
two belts over,
getting bags,
not telling everybody so they can get out in the taxi line before anybody else.
Then there's going to be a stampede of fucking people.
This is basically what's going to happen.
And this is the reason why I don't check a bag.
Okay?
But in loyalty and dedication to you
in our little family unit,
I chose to do that.
So all of this shit's going to be going down.
All right?
As we stand there going,
what the fuck's going on?
Meanwhile I can be over there getting the car,
all right?
And then I could get the car and just as the belt starts,
I could already be driving back smiling,
waving B,
B.
Right?
I like picking up my car to,
to be be.
Um,
so much to my surprise,
she goes
all okay.
And I'm like,
yes.
Right?
So I don't know if you guys have ever been to Boston,
but I don't know what this fucking city has against signage.
They have plenty of signs,
but none really tell you where to go.
They're all sort of vague and there's arrows pointing you in the general
direction.
And then at the last second,
the place you want to be after,
you want to make the turn right behind that road.
As you're driving 40 miles an hour will be assigned,
pointing at the road that you're currently passing
with whatever it is that you're looking for.
In the smallest print
ever.
So
I get on the bus,
I walk out the buses right there.
I'm like,
Bam,
all right,
I have my fucking,
you know,
I got my confirmation number and everything.
I see some dad coming out,
his,
his family all gets on the bus.
He has to carry ons in a child seat.
Where's the wife?
She's with the kids.
She carried the kids on,
you know the ones that can walk with their own power and they'd go and sit down.
So this poor bastard runs back to the curb to get the child seat.
All these fucking assholes on the bus or just staring at the guy.
It's like people,
we're all in the same team here.
We can't go until this guy.
This poor bastard gets all this shit on the bus.
How about you help out?
Right.
Everybody stand in this.
So the guy comes fucking running over.
He's got this stupid chair,
the child's seat things.
So I just reach out and he hands it to me,
right?
And he just fucking,
I don't even think he said thank you.
He fucking runs back.
I put the chair up where it needs to go.
He shows up with the other two bags.
I help them up with one,
blah,
blah.
And he sets everything down and I'm waiting for a big,
hey man,
thanks a lot.
You know,
little dad,
fist bump,
he doesn't say anything.
He just looks at his wife and smiles and goes,
they're all on and then walks back to where his wife and kids are.
And all I'm thinking is,
what a fucking,
where's my pat on the back?
I didn't have to do that.
It didn't say a fucking word.
So then immediately in my head I'm like,
oh,
this kid,
he's got a fucking management position does and he's got an expense account.
You know,
like he'd be on the fucking rental car bus.
I was just like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
This guy,
somebody's boss and he's a Douche.
I shouldn't have done that.
Right?
Whatever.
So the bus is pulling up,
it's fucking jam packed with people and I'm doing a fucking head count,
right?
We go by the Blue Line,
a third of the bus gets off and aren't thinking is a fuck.
I recently just switched over to hertz because budget has their head up their
ass.
So
all I'm thinking is I gotta get off this fucking bus and I gotta be part of that
first third so I'm not standing in the line cause my wife is probably,
God knows now that over here it's probably getting the bags and she's going
be like,
see it wasn't that it.
See I was actually right.
See
so anyways,
yeah
the bus doors open.
I'm the second person off the bus.
It's one of those buses that's dragging another bus.
That's how big it is.
And I shamelessly,
with my backpack sprint past everybody.
Sprint 49 years old.
Alright.
Sprinting.
But it ended at the,
the bed
[inaudible]
fucking running NFL films could have filmed this and showed it and fucking slow
motion,
right?
Yeah.
Burn it.
Baron and baron about apparently.
Okay.
Bucket run by everybody.
I'm the first person in,
there's one person in line and hurts and he's already being helped and I fucking
run
all the way up and I'm right fucking there and wouldn't,
you know,
I couldn't believe it.
There was some other lady up there and she just goes,
hello sir,
welcome to hurts.
Can I help you out?
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is so much better than budget.
Okay.
I got my fucking reservation number ready cause I know,
I know they're not going to have my car ready because this is everything.
It's going,
it's going too good.
So she goes,
what's the last name?
And I go bar.
She goes,
bar.
Oh,
I have your reservation reservation right here.
I'm like,
you've gotta be kidding me.
I goes in an SUV,
it's an SUV.
Do you got a kid seat?
We got a kid.
See you got one of those little Sadie save fucking Fucka um,
passes so I can go through the goddamn tunnel.
Yes,
we do.
Bang,
boom.
By smiling wave.
And she's great.
I get it,
I go,
you gotta be shitting me?
So I fucking walk out.
I make a right space number nine 10 there she is.
I throw my bags in the back.
I fucking get in the car
now trying to figure out how to get out.
There's like 50 signs that say egg,
the exit.
I'm driving in a fucking circle trying to get out of there and I stuck to start
losing my shit a little bit.
So every time I go to rent a car,
I always have to double back because everything says exit.
Yeah,
that'd be,
I'll says exit and then you realize,
oh,
that's for me.
If I just pulled out here,
it's so fucking stupid.
So I pull up and as you know,
I do the whole thing.
Hey,
thank you very much,
Yada Yada Yada.
We'll see you later.
And then rides on pulling out and go,
wait a minute,
is there a child seat in this thing?
I turn around,
there's no child seat.
I just talked to the lady.
Yeah,
the fucking way.
And she told me that it was going to be one in there like an asshole.
I took her fucking word for it.
I took a fucking word for it that these Goddamn fucking people,
we're going to put up a car seat and then they don't have it and I'm driving out
now.
I pull over and now there's somebody behind me beeping because I'm the
continental who's like looking back in disbelief.
I shut off the car.
I opened the back end.
That's right.
And then I got back in to see that there was no car seats.
So I'm starting to lose my shit.
This guy behind me beeps the horn.
I'm trying not to get mad and I'm like,
fucking cock suckers.
Lose my mind.
Now I've got to somehow figure out how to go back in.
So driving around and my brain's going,
don't call your wife right now.
Don't call your wife.
So what do I do?
Call my wife.
She picks up the phone.
I go near these fucking assholes.
Forgot to put a car seat in here.
She goes,
oh,
well we're here.
We have the bags.
But they didn't.
They lost my mom's bag and all of a sudden it's turning into planes,
trains and automobiles.
This nice smooth trip.
My kid was great,
my wife agreed that I could break off and actually officially get the car while
they wait for the bags.
They had my reservation,
they add every,
all the Cutera mall that I needed in the car.
And I was like,
I knew it.
I knew it was going to say.
And I just,
I,
uh,
somehow I went off on millennials,
like they're running hurts.
Like it's not a bunch of people from my generation and older.
Yeah.
And I fucking threw my hat down screaming at the top of my lungs.
Every curse word I could possibly muster up.
Go on these God damn fucking millennials,
they can't fucking do anything right.
Because they spend their entire life looking at a fucking screen.
They can't solve any problems.
Cause anytime they have a problem,
they either call,
their parents are fucking Uber and somebody shows up and pulls them out,
you know.
Okay.
Like a fucking helicopter pilot in Vietnam.
Yeah.
Just comes chopper and in and lifts them up out of their fucking problems.
So I fucking drive back
and I fucking pull in and as I come walking around,
getting ready for a battle,
this fucking hurt guy from parts comes walking out.
He goes,
hey,
how are ya?
I go,
yeah,
I was supposed to have a child seat.
I don't have one.
He goes,
well,
I can help you out with that.
And I was,
he was so nice.
He defused all my anger.
So he walks around the back,
he goes,
all right,
there's a child seats.
Which one do you want?
How old are you?
She goes,
which one do you want?
I go,
the one that's going to not make my kid die.
I was still a little angry and he kind of gave me a look like,
oof.
I was a little harsh.
So he goes,
I met,
how old is your kit?
I'm like,
11 months.
And he goes,
all right,
we got to,
we got a black one and we've got like a pinkish one a,
is it a boy or girl?
I go,
it's a girl.
He goes,
I'll,
we'll get the pink one.
And then he literally,
this a guy in his 60 [inaudible],
he goes,
not to say that,
did Jenny Take Ron via have a boy?
And I said,
dude,
you don't have to do that progressive shit with me any left.
You know,
like,
it's fine
not to
say if you wanted to raise,
you get gender neutral or your kid was already transitioning and 11 months,
you know,
started doing all that shit,
covering his tracks,
like he was fucking running for office.
So I'm like,
Oh my God,
this guy's great.
As always,
I flipped out.
I'm a fucking asshole.
I should have looked.
All I had to do was look,
and if I looked,
I could have just met this guy would have been fine,
right?
So he gives me the seat and the guy,
how do I get this in there?
He goes,
AH,
legally I'm not allowed to put that seed in or tell you how to do it for legal
purposes.
Any promptly turns and walks away
and he's walked away.
I'm like,
so that's it.
You just gotta walk away and he doesn't say a fucking word guy.
Smiley.
Just,
I know we heard me just turned and walked away and that was it.
And I was like,
oh,
so this is why the child's seat wasn't in there,
because they're not going to put it in there,
even though they know how to put it in there,
but they don't want to have the liability.
So of course now I go to put the fucking thing in there.
I figured out how to Hook it in and this thing has enough God damn slack on it.
It's like a fucking
give a see those youtube videos where they start,
you know they're filming some kid that they're pulling down the street and like
a fucking wagon or I dunno what a Boogie board or rezones skis with roller
skates.
That's how this things flying around.
I was just like,
fuck it.
We'll figure it out.
So I head back to United.
Oh,
here's another great thing about Logan Airport.
This is how bad signage is in Boston.
When you pull into Logan Airport,
just to give you a heads up,
if you drive back with the fucking rental car,
you're gonna drive into the airport.
There's going to be a giant fucking sign with every air carrier that they have
there at the airport.
It'll say letter a United fucking air,
uh,
air fucking Brazil,
blah,
blah.
Be Delta,
American Airlines,
Air Ethiopia,
Yada,
Yada.
All A,
B,
c,
d,
All right,
you have to drive by,
sift through every fucking airline there is.
Okay as you drive and by 30 miles an hour with somebody beeping behind you.
If you're lucky,
you find your airline.
And then for the love of God,
memorize the letter.
Because after that they're not listing any more fucking airlines.
It's just going to say B,
c,
d,
that's all a,
B,
c,
d.
And you got to remember what the fuck was mine.
Well,
where I was picking up the rental car,
I was already past that sign.
So now I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I have to call Nia
as I already went by a,
I'm like,
Nia,
what terminal you?
And she asked him,
he be right as I'm driving by beat and I fucking have to do this hard,
right?
I go in there and then right as I pull in,
I see on the,
um,
you know,
the exit where you turn in,
there's a sign that says be in a list.
All of them,
all the airlines,
super small.
But this is the greatest thing about Boston.
It's not before you get to the turn,
it's right after it
did the fucking worst out here.
So we pull in.
Okay.
And uh,
you know,
and of course it takes me another three phone calls once I'm in B to figure out
where the hell my wife is.
Okay.
We then fill up the fucking car.
Yeah.
You know,
there's not enough fucking room because they gave us like a midsize SUV.
I mean,
actually,
thank God my mother in law's a bag didn't come because we wouldn't have had the
fucking room anyways,
ended up being on the next flight and she got us.
Thank God for that.
So,
but now I'm thinking like when we go back to the airport,
I have to put somebody in a fucking cab with their bag.
Um,
and then
I get on.
So I've already lost my shit.
I lost it twice.
All right.
Once calling up the yet.
I guess that's once.
And then I lost my shit yelling about millennials for whatever reason,
as if they're already running hearts.
My apologies to millennials.
Okay.
You guys,
she just like hipsters.
Okay.
You're getting way more shit than you deserve.
You're not all bad.
All right.
So
I fucking,
and then I yelled at the,
I yelled at the fucking
car seat guy.
You know who now I don't believe his mood.
I think it was all just a tactic.
Hey,
how are you?
Absolutely.
Here's your kid's seat.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That was his vibe.
Um,
legally go fuck yourself.
So,
uh,
any wish I,
um,
I finally find where my laugh is we bring all the bags out,
we stick everything in,
and then I go to get on the Ted Williams tunnel,
which really is,
it really should have been
in an episode of the Dukes of Hazzard.
If they reboot the dukes of Hazzard as they're rebooting every fucking show.
MMM.
The amount of a fuck over that.
The big dig was
the fucking Ted Williams tunnel starts off.
It's four lanes across like,
wow,
this is great.
Then it goes down to three,
then it goes down to two who builds a fucking two laned fucking
tunnel.
Then the last 2030 years,
who the fuck has done that?
Like the entire big dig is,
it's like two fucking lanes that goes down to one lane or it's three down at the
whole fucking thing.
It's just everybody merging underground.
It is an absolutely fucking hellish traffic.
And all I could picture was all the people that scammed it,
living in giant houses with their own fucking helicopter flying over all of it,
not giving a shit,
which I'm sure is not true,
but in my head,
that all make sense.
So I ended up missing my turn when I came out of the tunnel because uh,
you know,
I'm in the tunnel,
my gps didn't work.
And so you actually get on the mass pike and their signage is so bad.
There's actually an exit.
You can get off work with all this signage on how to make a u turn to drive back
to the fucking exit that they know that you missed.
But this,
but they pocketed all the money for all this signage.
They should have fucking had to just have one fucking sign,
which is the u turn to send you back in.
Which is why everybody in Boston is so goddamn funny because they do shit like
that.
Laugh about it and pocket the money and then everybody else is having an
absolute shit fit,
flipping out saying hilarious stuff about millennials or God knows what.
Um,
I think I finally figured it out where they go.
Why are they so many fucking funny comedians that come out of Boston?
I would say because of the lack of signage.
It just keeps you in this.
Yeah.
Planes,
trains and automobile mode.
12 months out of the fucking year.
Everybody in Boston,
you know how they,
you know,
they know how to get to work.
Not because of the signs,
because they memorized it.
Everybody's going on fucking memory out here.
It's certainly not the fucking signs.
All right.
I think that made my goddamned point.
Let me do a little,
uh,
a little reading here.
But anyways,
we're here at the hotel.
Everything's good.
I actually worked out yesterday.
I'm going to try to stay on my diet and like pick my spots where I'm going to be
a,
or I'm going to be eaten bad,
but um,
whatever.
I don't have anything planned.
I just want to hang with family and friends.
It's gonna be great.
And you know what's awesome about having the kid is there's no,
no one gives a shit about you anymore.
It's perfect.
You kid is to start with the show.
You just come walking in.
Hey Bill,
how you doing?
Great.
You look at my kid.
Is My kid cute.
Oh my God.
Look at those cheeks.
It's over.
You just get to stand in the background sipping a drink.
Hello.
By the way,
you know my wife's giving me pressure.
She's like,
pill.
You're going to stay sober this whole fucking trip.
I can't go down to the hotel bar.
I'm a down the hotel bar.
I'll just get a little silicon and fucking the,
maybe call it a fucking soda or some shit.
What is that fucking drink that people order?
Can I get a a a club soda in a line.
There you go.
I'm getting it done and get it done.
Okay.
Draftkings everybody fantasy football season is coming to a close.
It's time for the Tony Awards.
Everyone and the sadness is really starting to set in.
Um,
how about just the football season is ending.
There's a word for your suffering,
seasoned itis.
But while your season long league might be done,
it's not too late to draft a new team and win money doing it with one week
fantasy football at draftkings.
At draftkings,
there are so many ways to play.
Choose from public contests with huge cash prizes or private contests where you
can compete against your friends there even they even got beginner and casual
contest where you play against people of a similar skill level.
The best part,
you don't have to.
I'm actually going to do this because I am ashamed at how few people's names I
know in the league.
I just wish I could order all,
you know,
the a complete set of football cards for the season.
I can look at him like flashcards when I did as a kid,
but my last time I tried to collect football cards in the two thousands.
It was only adults doing it,
so they would deliberately trying to make them rare.
Anyways.
Uh,
the best part is you get to draft a new team each week and drafting a team is
arguably the best part of fantasy aside from winning cache.
That is just,
that is,
okay.
Sorry.
Just as Travis from Los Angeles,
he turned a $300 entry into 1000 bucks or Gary from Houston who turned his $3
entry into 50 grand dod.
You must've had a fucking 10 teen Pilate,
huge cash prizes and bragging rights awake only at draftkings.
Why the fuck do I get credit for that?
If there's no god damn link,
I was going to go there,
click on the microphone and add my name burn.
They don't even tell me to do that.
Maybe only have got to half the copy.
I Dunno.
So that's it.
People,
that's all I got.
I got one read,
you know,
I'm down to like one advertiser now.
Whatever I ever did this to make money I did to make my tie my gigs to make
money.
So whatever,
whatever the fuck.
I'm not changing my style.
Okay.
These people don't like me fucking bringing up the clan every once in a while
during a fucking read.
What am I supposed to do?
My supposed to be like,
like that time Russia decided to jump on the hip hop wagon and make a fucking
rap song.
Is that what I'm supposed to do?
How did that work out for those guys?
You know,
somebody was trying to tell me that Neil pure,
the reason that he retires because his body hurts so much from all those years
of playing.
And uh,
that actually really made me sad and I was thinking like,
man,
that guy,
what he needs to do is just get a fucking really good misuse.
He must have one though.
I don't know.
You gotta get a jet.
I level misuse Seuss.
I swear to God.
Like the woman that I go to right now is working on my calves,
which had been glued up for like almost 50 years at this point.
I don't know what she's doing,
but she just takes like two fingers,
right?
And it just fucking presses against my calves.
It feels like I have a ball of Hornets in my fucking cat.
I wish you guys could see me in this thing.
I'm just coming up off the table like a fucking mirror kiss America.
Imagine a mere cat that's bald,
screaming in pain.
I just go,
I'll be like,
ah,
fucking cock suck.
And I'm not an athlete.
We all know this.
I do stand up comedy.
I can't have now I get why professional athletes like every week this sitting in
a tub of ice,
they're always get new,
fucking massaged and all of that cause a bodies is so god damn fucked up.
I feel like my body was like
how bad it got was PR,
which is why I have all of these injuries.
He's out of nowhere,
you know?
And I'm now down to one injury,
my fucking rotator cuff,
which I can't seem to get it to heal because I don't have the fucking patients.
And I miss playing drums too much and I just start,
I sit down and play and then I do something else to fuck it up again.
I'm such an idiot.
Um,
okay.
But anyways,
yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe cause I'm a fan or whatever.
I just hope that he finds a really good fucking like a Jedi level Miss Susur in
a good chiropractor and he takes a couple of years off and then he comes back.
Uh,
but a bad,
bad,
bad.
Got a damn.
Um,
anyway,
speaking of music,
a uh,
a good friend of mine,
you know,
is there anything,
should your friend ever a better friend than when they tell you about a new
fucking band that you end up loving?
Um,
I don't know what the name of the drummer is.
I Dunno if the name of the band is the name of the guy who's actually the
drummer.
I don't know.
But there's this band or this guy,
uh,
Yussef Kamaal and the name of the album is black focus and it's spelled y u.
S.
E.
F.
Komal is k a.
M.
A.
L.
All right,
dude.
I got to tell you,
the drumming,
the music,
first of all and the band is incredible,
but the drumming on this album,
the best way to describe it would be like if you could somehow merge
like a quest love type of player with Tony Williams.
MMM.
It's like that.
Breakbeat fucking James Brown quest love tight drumming,
uh,
with like that Tony Williams vibe,
even as like the black dot heads on his toms that has a little bit of that
sound.
It's fucking incredible.
Um,
and there's,
you got to listen to the album isn't enough.
Um,
I actually tweeted out a link to one,
two,
like the band playing live and the person,
thank God filming it was for once,
just on the drummer from the side.
And this guy is like,
he's one of those guys that it's just like he's playing from his spirit.
You know,
he's like in a trance when he's fucking playing.
He's unbelievable.
And,
uh,
I went online to see if they were going to be in the states.
They seem to be over in Europe right now,
but,
uh,
I will cancel a fucking Gig to go see that band.
That's how good they are.
Yousef,
Kamala,
the name of the album is black focus.
Check it out if you get a chance.
Uh,
what are we up to here?
Oh,
39 minutes and I'll look at that.
It's Christmas.
I'm giving you some extra time here.
Uh,
the Bruins,
by the way,
ruins,
I've got a two game win streak,
I believe,
and there's six and three in the month of December.
I finally have a chance to at least watch some of the highlights.
I've been so busy and a happy 20th birthday that shall we McAvoy who had his
first Gordie Howe hack trick the other night.
And for those who don't watch hockey,
a Gordie Howe hat trick is a goal and an assist in a fight.
He had his first fight.
MMM.
I would love to interview somebody.
Like a Charlie McAvoy where he's not a goon,
but like I would love to interview them as far as like,
cause he came up playing hockey.
I don't think he played in any league where you could fight.
So this was his first and he came right straight from bu last year in like march
or April and had an immediate impact.
Um,
so I think I'm,
I'm wondering if this was his first hockey fight period and like what is going
through your head when you go to drop the gloves?
Like,
and you're fighting on in Nhl love.
I mean,
fighting somebody alone is brutal now because someone's going to have this cell
phone camera,
but to actually do it on television and it takes a lot of fucking balls.
MMM.
I always wondered like what's going through their head and fighting on skates.
It's the only way to learn how to do it is to do it.
It's like stand up comedy.
Like you could stand in your room and fucking rehearse in front of a mirror,
but it's,
it's all out the window.
The second you get on stage,
it's like guitar where you could practice,
you know,
and rehearse with the band and all of that shit.
Even then you're just going to be that extra level of nervousness because now
people are watching you.
MMM.
That's my favorite thing about all of that stuff.
Like
mmm.
Doing any sort of acting in front of a crowd and all of that is just our plain,
you know,
rehearsing with the band and then playing in front of them.
I always loved that,
that rush of,
you know,
when you look at each other before you start is that like,
oh here it is,
all of that work.
Now here it is,
is this,
we're going to pull this off,
are we going to shit the bed or whatever.
And there's always that part that's the difficult part.
And you know where you've got like a lot of lines or like this,
some sort of drum fill and when you get on the other side of it and hopefully
pulled it off,
you're like,
oh,
it's all downhill.
And then you relax and then you fuck up.
I don't mean relaxed in a good way,
I should probably say loose focus.
Um,
and by the way,
that's something that I've been working on,
um,
with my,
my drumming is,
my teacher has been telling me forever.
He just basically to sum up what he says is 15 minutes a day of focused
practice.
See if I remember this,
15 minutes a day of focused practice is better than four hours of add playing,
which is what I would do.
Good Times,
bad times for a minute.
Oh,
uh,
tower power Squibb cakes.
Let me work on that for fucking two minutes.
Let me do this and blah,
blah blah.
And you just all over the fucking map.
It'd be literally like if you're trying to learn to speak another language and
rather than,
than just trying to learn a phrase or two a day and then sticking with that for
a week.
So it becomes part of something that you could just pull up immediately as you
think you would try to learn like 50 words a day and then the next day do 50
different words.
Um,
so I've really been working on,
on that and um,
and all I've been doing is just like a doubles working on just a double stroke
roll with accents.
And I've been working on that since fucking November and all of a sudden
something clicked.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm just,
I'm finally so fucking excited that,
uh,
that I've been able to do that.
So,
so if you're out there,
man,
woman,
transgendered person,
whatever drummer you are,
uh,
you know,
most creative people have massive levels of fucking add.
Um,
and it's not because you're stupid,
it's not because you lack focus.
He's just,
you have a very creative brain and you think of something which makes you think
of the next idea and the next idea and the next idea.
And practicing is not creating,
it's working on an idea that you have,
if that makes sense.
If you just work on that,
and I,
in my 15 minutes,
like I'll be playing doubles,
right?
And then all of a sudden I'll be like,
oh,
let's throw some paradiddles and a big bill bill back to the doubles.
He just had to keep like hitting the reset button and,
um,
that alone,
like I had to practice out of focus as fucked up as that sounds.
But you know,
if you work on it a little bit every day,
um,
you know,
cause I figured if I could fucking do it to my lack of musical ability,
if musicians who listen to this,
if you actually fucking try that on any instrument or whatever,
I'm telling you,
um,
you'll start to see results.
It's fucking awesome.
Um,
that you can apply the playing.
It's fucking amazing.
So anyways,
um,
the Celtics were the bro Burns today have Winnipeg,
and then on Saturday they have the red wings and then the Celtics have the bowls
that night.
All right.
And back in the day before I was a dad,
I would have gone to both games a little Bingo.
Banga and I carry my buzz from the Bruins game right into the Celtics.
Um,
but,
uh,
I'm a dad now,
so I can't fucking do that switch means I'll watch the game.
But I am going,
I'm going to the Celtics bowls.
I am doing that.
MMM.
[inaudible]
chicken,
a couple of family members there for a little Christmas celebration there.
Um,
I know it's just the bowls,
but the next time they plays on Christmas Day and that's not going to work out.
All right.
My stomach's growling here.
I got to go get somebody.
All right.
Uh,
merry Christmas to everybody.
Happy Hanukkah,
appy,
Kwanzaa,
happy.
Uh,
I don't celebrate the holidays to you.
Whatever it is.
A Hey,
you made it.
You made it to 2017,
2018.
It's going to be even better for you.
All right?
Uh,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
You'd cuts and I will talk to you on Monday,
hopefully about another Patriot victory over the buffalo bills.
All right,
see you.
[inaudible]
the one
on his Belper and it is the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
December 21st,
2000.
Who will die?
What's going on?
How the hell are you?
How are you last week?
Did you miss me?
Um,
I actually was surprised how many emails I got were people like,
do what happens?
You'll fucking die.
Just making sure you're all right.
You know,
fucking Brittany Murphy died.
did you die?
I felt really bad about that.
You know,
if you've known,
I never saw any of her movies,
but you know,
if I felt as bad as you feel when somebody you don't know dies,
you know,
I hate when people try to get light when they get overly sad about somebody
famous dying because you know,
you never met them and then they try to use it as an excuse to get out of
working.
No,
you don't understand.
I used to watch clueless with my mother.
We watch to like every day I just,
I can't function right now.
Shut up.
You fucking Lazy Twat go in there and do your end of the year bullshit so we can
get on with the fucking Christmas party.
You know,
you didn't know her.
Okay.
You didn't know her.
I didn't know or nobody knows her.
Well,
people know are,
but nobody,
we know.
You fucking idiot.
Just do your fucking job.
Um hmm.
Wow.
Little intense there.
Um,
basically I didn't do a special last week because,
um,
I was under the weather and as you can tell,
I'm still getting over it.
I have the,
uh,
and I think I have the swine flu,
you know,
a little of that little that going on.
I just say the Christmas cookie,
I made a Christmas cookie.
Did you make a Christmas cookie?
You're forgiven fair.
Yes I did.
I keep the holiday traditions alive in my house.
You know,
I don't go home for the holidays anymore.
And you know what?
I bet a lot of you are wishing you don't.
If you're stuck in an airport and if you are,
I feel for you because I've been there and what you're going through right now
is the exact fucking reason that I don't go home for the holidays other than the
fact that I had to get on with my life here,
um,
is I'm telling you,
and you go anywhere where it,
even remotes remotely has a snowflake and the day you're going to travel,
God knows there's going to be four inches of fucking snow and the weathermen are
going to act like it's going to be 40 feet of snow.
You know,
that's one thing I,
I've,
I've noticed in my lifetime where somehow weather has become like an action
movie,
you know,
and they cats my girlfriend leaving,
closing the squeaky door,
no concern for the recording.
Um,
you know,
broad [inaudible] they're going to do what they want to do,
you know?
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
but back in the day there was four inches of snow.
That was it.
It was,
it's gonna snow on Thursday.
It wasn't like,
oh my God,
Angie vaccines,
none your,
they always fucking scare the shit out of old people.
Right.
And they fucking,
you know,
those idiots,
it's like four inches of snow and people going down on the supermarket like
buying provisions,
you know,
gun powder and bread and shit.
It's like,
it's four inches of fucking snow.
You know,
what is the worst case scenario?
The scenario,
right?
What is it?
Four inches of snow,
even for a little old lady is up to your ankles.
Okay.
If you have a problem,
people can get to you.
You know,
even if there was a foot of snow,
which is a lot of fucking snow.
Okay.
And let's just say you didn't have any food,
you can still just take a handful of fucking snow,
stick it in the glass,
let it melt,
and then let it cool down so you don't get a fucking snow cone headache.
And then you have water and you can live for a long time on just water.
It's only a foot of snow.
These fucking assholes.
They scare the shit out of people.
So,
uh,
I don't know what this has to do with people being stranding and stranded in an
airport.
All I can say is I'm so site,
I'm not one of those people.
Um,
but anyways,
getting back to me,
um,
last week I did my,
uh,
my,
my latest standup special,
uh,
let it go and I did it at the a,
the Fillmore in San Francisco,
the original Fillmore.
And right now you should be going,
well,
what do you mean you original film?
Or what does that mean?
Uh,
I thought that that was the Fillmore west,
but evidently it is.
And it's the Fillmore auditorium where I think they were there from like,
I don't know,
65 to 68.
And then 68 they moved down to market street and that became the Fillmore West.
That's where Zeppelin and I think the WHO and all those guys played.
So I was a little disappointed when I played the Fillmore and realized that when
I went into the green room bathroom,
I wasn't actually urinating in a place where John Bonam took a shit.
I was a little disappointed with that.
But um,
my girlfriend is wearing some sort of fervor vest.
What is that?
What old lady died and then you bought that.
Is that like a state jewelry acceptance of vest?
Does that make any sense?
You're little Cruella Deville Ensemble.
I'm your desk.
You're dressed very sensibly.
I can see why you put it on.
Then you put it on the little first thing to add a little little edge to you.
So people be like,
you know,
he didn't want to be plain Jane during the holidays.
No,
I hate those fucking shoes with a passion.
If you always,
if you ever,
if you wore those shoes on the first date,
there never would have met a second day
rally.
You can think of the,
add those things in fucking,
she's got these Bruce shot up,
she's got these Bruce Lee Karate fucking flats.
They're horrible.
They're ballet flats.
Well,
what did that prove?
All right,
get outta here.
Um,
Duh.
Doesn't everybody just happen?
You know,
your girlfriend has that pair of shoes.
You just fucking hate her comfortable shoes.
These are thug.
I like them.
They're comfortable.
You know,
I swear to God and she left.
it's fucking unbelievable is,
you know what's funny is when you hook up,
you have a hookup with a short girl,
you know,
and you see her in a Khaleesi or in the club,
right?
And Your Dad sin,
Don't worry,
I'm going to get to Jersey shore.
Uh,
and you got like the fall.
Let's talk about that right now.
Let's talk about that little sneaky girl.
Okay,
let's just,
let's just say she didn't have fucking triple f tidies.
Let's just say she didn't have those and she was more proportioned.
Um,
I'm actually convinced that she actually doesn't have a torso.
She just has ass and titties and the ass or is at the same level as,
as her titties,
um,
whatever.
You know,
the short girls and they were like those four inch fucking heels and it just
makes them,
their legs look unbelievable.
And you know,
I swear to God,
you have to bang them in those shoes because when you get them out of the shoes,
you just,
it's like
they become like this little dwarf all of a sudden and they're walking around
and they have that little thong on and you just,
it just,
it's fucking weird.
You know what I'm saying is,
is,
you know,
you meet a girl and you go out there and what are they dress up and then they're
looking at their shoes.
Okay.
And they're like,
which shoes am I going to wear?
I got to look sexy,
but I,
I can't make it look like,
you know,
every time I see a dick,
I'm diving on it like a war hero of dives on a fucking live grenade,
you know?
Ah,
that's a fucking great image.
Just dive in on a fucking,
Oh,
you filthy horse.
So they leave those shoes,
they leave those,
I'm getting over my boyfriend shoes at home.
Right.
Um,
that Kim could trails,
they leave those at home and that,
but they,
they date,
they definitely,
you know,
they definitely sex the fucking thing.
I'm so whatever.
Then they get you,
you know,
you fall from whatever then in a relationship and then there's that one fucking
day where they feel comfortable enough to wear their little comfortable shoes
and they're just,
you know,
toes and fucking and heal are just on the same legislative flats.
They were their fucking flats and they're little stretch pants and all of a
sudden you,
it's like you're walking around with like this soccer mom and it's like,
what happened in the fucking Hottie,
you know,
that I saw at work,
right at work.
Listen to me,
I sound like Seinfeld
deal,
whether you're comfortable,
why aren't you drizzling?
Oh,
um,
yeah,
so those are hers.
She wears ballet flats and I swear to God,
you know,
I know I bring up the leg sweep a lot,
but every time I see him,
I just,
you know,
you ever been like in a store with your girlfriend and she's just annoying you
and you just start having this like,
this fantasy of like,
what if I just walked away?
Yeah.
Right.
Like,
seriously.
What if I just walked away?
Like for good?
Like if it,
well,
what did we,
what it was that easy to get out of a fucking relationship,
you know,
there wasn't a talk that wasn't like the whole,
yeah.
You know,
I'm just not you.
It's me.
I'm just,
I'm not happy.
And,
uh,
it's not fair for you,
for me to still be in this thing when you should be out there and you should be
with a guy who,
who,
you know,
is going to give you all those emotional things that I,
I can't,
and I don't know why it is,
but I need to go figure it out and I'm just very painful for me to do.
I have a lot of guilt and uh,
well even feeling this way,
uh,
for the last three minutes,
you know,
you can't,
you can never say like I probably since the second date,
but you know,
you were fucking me.
Good.
So I stuck around and uh,
here it is eight months later and uh,
I've always hated this couch.
So
sorry,
go ahead.
Take a drink there.
You don't want to be great for you.
You just,
you just fucking walk away.
I've always been envious of those people who like abandoned their families.
Not that they do that,
that's like a terrible thing to do.
But like,
I want to feel that euphoria at some point in my life.
Can you imagine how fucking unhappy you are as a man?
That you have a wife and children and you are so miserable
that you're actually contemplating just walking away from it all,
you know?
Okay.
But it's like a fantasy.
You're not going to you like,
I can't,
I got kids.
I can't fucking do that.
I can't be that fucking piece of shit.
Like in a blues song,
you'd go out to get cigarettes.
He never come back again.
But the guys who actually fucking do,
and I know there's a loneliness,
I know there's a guilt,
but that feeling right as you're standing in the doorway to your kitchen on the
weighty a back door,
you know,
and she's just sitting there giving you shit or whatever the fuck it is that
she's just,
she's eaten that English muffin.
The way she eats it and the side of her fucking temples are going in and out and
you just can't stand it.
She's doing that thing the way she clears her throat.
Right.
And you're like just going like,
hey honey,
I'm going to go return this video.
Okay,
Gia.
Hey,
when you make,
when you learn your way,
Huh?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Daniella.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
and then you get in the car.
You already got your fucking bag of clothes in there or some shit.
I mean,
it should drive it out.
The dry mean.
You just must be who like what song do you fucking listen to?
What is the soundtrack as anybody ever abandoned a family?
Any listeners?
What Song were you listening to on your iPod when you turn the fucking corner,
you know,
you gotta feel like Tim Robbins when he comes up out of that fucking sewer
water.
You know,
and I'm sure you have your fantasy that you're going to be sitting there on a
beach building a boat,
you know,
with some Tan tidied Hati that you met on fucking Facebook,
right?
And just when you think she's going to find you and you're going to have to pay
child support,
you look up,
who is it?
It's fucking Morgan Freeman and a little reservoir dogs sue with a fucking bing
Crosby hat.
Right?
I know that's what you fantasize about,
but then you end up in a fucking motel six.
We won't go there.
But I would love to feel that fucking,
that euphoria.
You know,
I felt it a few times when I had skipped school that will be driving on the way
to school and all of a sudden I just think,
you know what?
I don't feel like going today.
And I would keep going and it just,
with no power whatsoever that I could control my emotions.
I would just break into an ear to ear grin and I would,
I have just,
you know,
go to a fucking movie.
You know,
I did.
I still by myself,
I'd skip school by myself.
I came in,
what the fuck I do.
I drive around.
I would drive out to fucking,
uh,
I go look at the fucking spot,
a nerd I was,
I'd go out and I go look at a Sullivan stadium where the Patriots used to play.
I just go look at it,
you know,
go out,
go get a fucking breakfast at like the Ihub just thinking I'd be in math class
right now I'm eating pancakes and I should be listening to some guy talking
about first outside,
inside last,
right.
I mean,
how the fuck I got on this subject when you're talking about shoes,
we were talking about shoe.
So anyways,
you probably wondering,
Bill,
how did the taping go?
Well,
if he can hear the fucking joy in my voice,
I can't help you.
It was awesome.
The first show when fucking great.
And then the second show was just,
it was over the top.
And I'm like I said,
it was at the Fillmore,
absolutely legendary place.
They had all these day of,
um,
all the posters from all the bands that have played there.
You know,
recently they have that room and then they have the classic room where they
literally had posters,
like a pink Floyd poster that said it said from England,
Pink Floyd.
It just gave me chills to read it.
Like they were like pink Floyd was that knew that they needed some something
they needed like a hook to get people to go see him.
And the hook was that they were from England,
you know,
cause the whole,
the Beatles,
the rolling stones at that point.
And I think,
I think the,
who had already been here at by that point,
I don't know why,
but like,
you know,
the whole British invasion that happened.
So they had this,
you know,
pink fucking Floyd from England and from England.
I think you ought to give them a chance.
They Call Pink Floyd.
I know it's a weird name.
They had all those kinds of posters.
They had a posted there for Lenny Bruce.
I found out he did his last performances were right there.
And um,
it just gave me goosebumps and uh,
it was great.
The first show,
the first show went great.
I was sweating a little bit because I had taken this fucking dayquil and the
combination of that in the spotlight.
So it got to the point about,
you know,
two thirds of the way through my set,
I had to fucking towel myself off like I was playing racket ball.
So,
uh,
yeah,
anything past that I'm not going to use that,
you know,
I'm not going to be able to,
cause the second one went,
went off without a hitch.
I didn't take any cold medication and I just,
you know,
I already knew I had a great taping and then send them the second one.
I just went off and a,
I literally felt like I was standing in a comedy club and I was going through 10
to 15 minute chunks where I wasn't even aware.
I wasn't even thinking that I was taping a special,
you know,
I definitely knew I was,
but I w I wasn't like thinking about that.
There were cameras there.
I was just focusing on what I was saying.
I kind of learned this trick out of trick my head into doing that,
which is basically I improv a little bit up front,
which saps me into the presence,
the present,
you know,
as opposed to me and in robot mode.
So I want anyways,
it was fucking unbelievable.
They made me a poster so my poster is actually going to be hanging there.
I don't know how long they'll hang it there because uh,
you know,
it's one of those deals they revolve them around and who the fuck am I?
But for a moment it's going to be hanging in there.
Um,
and uh,
I don't know.
My parents came out,
they stuck out all my friends and family in this,
this VIP,
um,
you know,
like,
like you don't like the old guys on the muppets.
It was something like that in the back of the room and the whole town would just
stick in there.
Like Bill Graham probably stood there the first time he wants Jimmy Hendrix.
It was,
it was fucking unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
And,
um,
I actually,
I don't know.
I was,
I was beyond site at the end of it and uh,
and then the second and ended,
I finally fucking relaxed a little bit.
And then that's when the sickness that had been trying to get me just completely
took over.
But I didn't give a fuck at that point.
And I battled it with some alcohol,
but whatever.
I want to thank everybody who came out to,
uh,
my,
my tapings.
It was,
it's something that I will never ever forget,
um,
to perform in a venue that legendary was very humbling and I'm so psyched that I
had,
um,
I dunno,
I want to say,
I think I had the best performance I've had for a TV taping up to this point in
my career.
And,
uh,
it was awesome.
And I want to thank everybody who went,
including this guy who sent me an email after the,
uh,
the taping a under the title of lackluster and this guy has earned douche bag of
the week.
Yes.
Everybody.
Um,
this is one of these things where you just can't please everybody and you know
what kind of a content we would send somebody an email like this,
you know,
lack luster.
This is the beauty of the Internet that I,
that I really find.
I think the Internet is fucking hilarious.
How just any random shithead,
you know,
I don't know if it's just me cause I pretty much read all my emails,
but like,
you know,
if you got something bad to tell me this,
you got a 90% chance,
I'm going to fucking read it.
Um,
I just think that's funny because back in the day,
you know,
I used to watch TV and I'd be watching people go,
this guy's and fucking funny.
Or there's this guy sucks.
Why does he keep doing movies?
But I,
but it was just to the TV or to the guy sitting next to me.
I couldn't actually get it to the person.
So,
uh,
you know,
how about that for technology?
So this is what the guy writes.
He writes bell.
To be honest,
I was disappointed at your Fillmore show.
Um,
I am a big fan,
but I am also a realist.
I don't even know what that means.
I guess that means he was expecting something big,
but I didn't deliver and I have to be honest with you,
bill,
you didn't deliver.
I mean,
what a cunt,
right?
He goes,
first off,
I was very disappointing,
very disappointed at the recording of audience applause and laughter.
I thought it was the opening guys last bit.
I was the asshole that booed.
Laughter and applause tracks are weak.
What he's saying is right before they brought me on the opening act said,
okay,
we need you guys to do us a favor.
Okay,
I'm going to count to three.
And when I count to three,
I want you guys just,
everybody laughed.
Like you just heard something that was kind of funny.
And then one,
two,
three in the crowds,
like Ah,
whatever.
Right?
And they go,
okay,
that was great.
That was great.
All right.
Now this time I want you to laugh a little bit more like you'd like to act like
that was,
that was really funny and they laugh a little bit louder and then they go,
okay,
that was great.
Now the third time I want you guys to laugh like this is the funniest thing
you've ever heard.
One,
two,
three and everybody why but he's going is crazy so this guy booze and he says,
you know audience applause,
tracks and laughter are weak.
You know
sir,
this is why you are Douche bag of the week because what you did was you assumed
that we were recording those in an effort just in case I bombed that.
We were good.
Then going to use those to drop in laughter.
But we were actually doing sir,
was we were testing the levels of the audience and we wanted to make sure that
we were going to be able to capture anything that the audience did,
that if they found something mildly funny,
that the mix would be up enough where they would pick it up,
but they wouldn't be up so much that if people went crazy.
What happens is,
is if oh fit like overloads,
I don't know what the technical thing is.
The microphone shuts off basically when it red lines,
it's almost like a car or something.
Like it seizes up,
it just stops.
So what you have to do before you go out there is you have to make sure that you
have your mix at the right level and you do it with every crowd.
Cause every crowd is different.
It's a different group of people.
There's a different energy.
And what you're trying to do is you've got to capture that live sound of the
room.
So what we were doing there sir,
was we were basically doing an audience,
um,
like a soundcheck,
like,
you know,
when the artist comes out,
he's like [inaudible] test one,
two,
hey,
hey Yo,
you know all that shit that they do and what you're supposed to do is also be,
you know,
bringing your voice up loud,
going away from the Michael and Liz,
there's a way to do it or whatever.
They were basically doing that for you because they had already done a sound
check for me.
So that's what they were doing.
You fucking moron.
All right.
And I understand that you're not in this business so you should know what that
is,
but you know,
there was plenty of people standing around from the crew that you could have
asked before you left before you went on Facebook and fucking trash me.
Like I'm like a,
um,
I'm trying to get,
you know,
that would be almost like,
like I lip sync to my act.
That's so,
that's not what was happening,
sir.
All right,
you fucking douchebag Jesus.
Maybe.
Maybe at Santos,
next special.
I'm going to make sure the openers says,
look,
and we're not going to use these.
What we're doing is we're basically doing a soundcheck.
And plus if this guy had half a brain,
he would've listened to the laughter because most people were not laughing.
What they were doing was they were going,
woo.
You know,
and the funniest thing ever there was screaming.
So it didn't,
the audio wouldn't have sounded like I told the joke or what.
It sounded like some drunk jumped up on stage and was about to take his dick
out.
That's what the crowd sound likes.
I always actually backstage laughing when I was listening to it.
Um,
so there you go,
sir.
That's,
that's what was going on.
And then he also goes on to say that he just recently hits,
he saw my last show at the punchline and that he was disappointed that when he
went to go to the DVD recording that he barely heard any new material.
So he was basically mad that he saw me getting ready for my special.
And then when he went to go see my special,
that the jokes that I was working on during the night that he saw me,
we're the same jokes.
This guy is such a fucking moron and so many levels.
It's like you can't go out and wing a special,
sir.
You can't do it.
Comics have tried it.
I've seen comics go out with a legal pad and some ideas written down there and
you'll have moments where you're riffing and it's going great,
but there's a reason why you don't do that.
All right?
You've got to have the act okay to Improv.
Even like these fucking Improv people who are in these improv groups and they
try to act like the whole fucking thing they do well,
it's all off the top of the head.
The fucking audience suggest Shit,
you know?
And it's really just off the top of your head the first fucking time you do it
because the more you do those in,
because I used to watch this in Prague group every week.
They used to come down to the laugh factory.
The first time I saw,
I was like,
wow man,
it's fucking amazing.
But you start watching it after awhile and you're like,
oh,
that guy always does this.
This person always does that.
And you know,
and then there's also repeat suggestions.
Give me a job and it's a job you've heard before.
You know,
I'm not shitting on those guys,
but you know,
it's one of those deals.
So that's the deal,
sir.
That's why you heard the same material and that's why you heard,
uh,
and that's why we were doing the applause tracks.
Okay.
So I am not,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you do,
but you know,
that's really fucking annoying that you,
that you,
that,
you know,
to have to read a fucking email like that and one of the best nights of my
fucking career to have put,
I mean,
that's,
that's power for the fucking course.
What are you going to do?
You know,
what are you going to fucking do?
So there you go.
This douche bag of the week.
I'm trying to do more of these,
uh,
my old little standards here.
Whatever.
You want to call them,
a different topics here because somebody actually sent me an email telling any,
you know,
you'd never do any of your topics anymore.
And,
uh,
I think the person was right.
So I'm trying to a to get back to that shit.
So,
uh,
let's read a couple more emails here.
This one's going to be a little bit short because I haven't done any fucking
Christmas shopping because I've been,
uh,
getting ready to do my special.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
built.
Now here's,
here's,
this is an email that I got from somebody and this really amazed me.
This minds set amazes me and I understand that I am not a doctor and that I am
not a scientist.
So,
uh,
I really can't medically defend my positioning other than I just think I'm right
on this one.
All right.
Um,
all right,
Bill,
I dunno if you will actually do a subject for this,
but I've gotten a ton into a ton of arguments with friends slash strangers about
how now it's being said that homosexuals are born homosexuals.
They're saying it's like a gene.
Personally,
I think it's the dumbest fucking thing I've ever heard.
And to me it seems like a big excuse.
So the world will leave the gay community alone.
I didn't know the world was,
was bugging them.
Um,
I've been leaving the gay community alone my entire life.
Oh,
that's not true.
I laughed.
It's a lot of homophobic shit when I was younger,
you know.
All right.
Hang on a second.
Fuck.
Anyways.
Personally,
if you want a dick in your ass,
by all means get her done.
There's a major red flag.
Ah,
people are still saying that.
You know,
you got to dream in life.
Keep on trucking a whoop.
There it is.
Um,
just think it's a choice anyways.
I just think it's a choice.
And you choose to be a flame or um,
if you want to get tactical,
then how dumb would it be to say,
yeah,
dude,
fucking Michael Jordan had a gene in his body and he was born out of the vag to
be a basketball player.
I think it's absolute bullshit.
And if you are gay,
who gives a fuck about what the world thinks?
Just do what you want and screw everybody.
Right.
And they're also saying being gay is the new black,
uh,
who,
who are these people who are saying this?
Are they saying this on TV?
That sounds like a fashion show.
Yeah.
Oh,
next up gay is the new black.
Oh yeah.
Mother fuckers.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
But comparing homosexuals to African Americans seems like the biggest slap in
the face to the black community.
These guys really big on saying community and giving back handed compliments.
Um,
anyway,
I'm a moron.
And if you,
uh,
what's your opinion on the subject?
Uh,
yeah,
I would agree with you.
You are a moron and a no.
I think gay people are born that way and yes,
I think Michael Jordan was Michael Jordan was born with a gift.
Do you think you can just practice?
You know,
no matter how proud,
hard I practiced to fuck it,
I could never take off from the fire line,
dunk a basketball.
I could never change the game.
He changed the fucking game.
He was born,
he was born with a gift.
He was,
um,
I don't think that that's a,
that's a,
uh,
that's a good example though.
Cause you're talking about something more like that was a gift.
Well you should have used it as an example.
That's like saying you were,
you came,
you w you were born just to like pussy.
You know,
what was the big turning point in your life,
sir?
Where there was a dick on the table and a vagina.
Do you remember like what was it that made you finally make the decision that
you are going to like women think about it.
They never really was a choice was there,
you just did.
It was just natural within you and someone could have made you aware of fucking
dress.
You know,
your whole fucking child.
Did you still want a bank j lo,
because that's how you're wired.
All right?
So
you know,
get your head out of your ass.
You fucking moron.
You're a moron.
All right.
I actually went back and forth text messaging and then he brought up the Bible.
How it says that the fucking Bible you just said,
you know,
God Damn Bible,
I swear to God,
I can't,
I can't get over how stupid most are.
Who read the fucking Bible where they're reading this stuff and it's supposed to
make them this,
this,
this more,
uh,
I don't know what holy or person.
And all it does is it just creates this fucking resentment to other people and
everything they,
they,
they fucking end up doing is like,
they just are lashing out at other people and it's just like,
how do they not see the fucking irony in that?
It doesn't even make any sense.
And how do you not understand that God didn't write that book and Dark God
wasn't yelling down from,
you know,
[inaudible] you know,
he wasn't doing that.
All right.
The 10 Commandments,
first of all are up,
came from people.
All right.
This is ridiculous.
I'm saying this like,
I know this for fact,
but
I dunno.
I think,
I think all of that.
I think morality,
unless you're born a sociopath,
morality is within you.
And I think your feelings have a higher power and afterlife,
all of that are within you.
And that natural feeling of when you do something good,
you feel good,
and when you do something bad,
you feel bad.
Is
that to me is the higher power.
I don't need to go into a frigging church or any of that.
Okay.
I believe in all that meditating.
I believe in a lot of stuff,
but I also believe that the same way you guys could be going like,
dude,
what is this based in?
You don't know what the fuck you talking about.
That's but neither have the people in the church.
They don't know either.
They've never died.
They don't know what the fuck.
It's all fucking guests,
but all I know
is that you know,
I'm not going to walk around and starting to fucking hate people because some
fucking book that some guy wrote,
you know,
thousands of years.
It's stupid.
It's fucking stupid.
All right.
You don't know what you're talking about,
sir.
The same way you naturally like,
okay,
if being gay was a choice than being heterosexual would be a choice.
And at some point in your life,
you got to tell me when you made that choice,
when you were sitting there,
you know when you were looking at Tommy and you were looking at Stephanie and
you're like,
ah,
how am I going to play this?
How am I gonna fucking play this?
You know,
think about it.
There's that time when you're a little kid,
whereas a boy,
girls are gross.
You're like,
ah,
that grows and they touch here and then you got fucking germs and then you
fucking wipe it off.
You try to touch somebody else with,
remember that,
that dumb shit.
But during that point,
because you're finding them repulsive,
you're not looking at your best buddy going,
oh,
what I love to get him in the tree fort.
You know,
you just go play football.
Then gradually get a little bit older,
right?
The girls get a little more physically attractive,
is that looking at their fucking clams and then you're in there and you spend
the rest of your life chasing it and it's totally,
completely 100% natural and that's,
you just flip around.
That's what gay guys do.
It's the same fucking thing.
It's not as she just born that way.
Stop being a fucking hateful comment.
All right,
there we go.
Oh,
that was very,
we are the world,
isn't it?
Look at me being all fucking accepting of people I don't hate.
Like,
like people like that.
Like if,
if a gay guy fucking is in front of me and he doesn't pull all the way out in
the fucking intersection,
you know,
so I can make the light too.
You know,
that's when I hate the guy,
you know,
fucking pull all the way out day you fucking cock sucker.
But it has to do with his driving,
not with his sexual preference.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
broads,
this is the next topic.
Uh,
I need to,
um,
include myself into the manipulative discussion by mentioning,
I think he's talking about women here mentioning the occurrences of female
friends who seem to think you should do what a boyfriend would do even though
you're not and never will be their boyfriend.
Um,
my story is this.
I recently reconnected with the girl on Facebook that I basically just knew.
I knew of in high school and maybe had three conversations with in the whole
four year run.
All right.
He recently connected with her.
In other words,
he wanted to bang her back in the day,
but he either felt he was too much of a loser.
Yeah.
I recently reconnected.
You seek her out.
I wonder what she's doing that she's still look good.
God Damn even better.
She's 28,
probably knows how to suck a dick now.
I think I'm going to reconnect.
Good move sir.
Good move.
Um,
she likes cool music and I like cool music so we could connect on various videos
we posted,
etc.
Working your way in virally.
I liked this.
Um,
she was coming to New York where I live,
perfect.
From our home town for Thanksgiving sensor brother lives in Brooklyn.
Um,
now I was friends with her brother,
so I thought it would be cool to hang out with them at a bar.
Now it's getting a little weird.
You're friends with her brother and you're trying to bang her sister.
Um,
I'm really super imposing my thoughts.
Why don't I shut the fuck up and just read this.
Okay,
here we go.
Um,
everything went fine.
We had our drinks caught up on what we could catch up on and I thought that um,
I thought should,
should be at,
besides email,
left out some words and I thought that should,
I don't know,
some bullshit Facebook where it however some band is playing in New York and she
wants to go.
I think the band is fine,
but I'm not a real big fan.
All right.
I know.
I just couldn't read that last,
the previous sentence of basically she wants to go see a band that he's not
really into.
Um,
she seems to have her to heads that sense.
I happen to live in New York and I guess she has no one else to go see the
bandwidth that I should automatically to go with her to see a band.
I don't want to see with someone who was a friend and only the loosest of terms
I said I would pass.
And then that produced a flurry of passive aggressive emails.
The intent of which makes me feel like I rejected her,
of course,
that uh,
wasn't it,
but also what would it matter?
I barely know her.
Any reasonable person,
which should suggest the idea and if the idea isn't accepted would move on,
but she can't possibly go by herself.
So she's trying to manipulate me with self pity.
She just doesn't want to be alone.
She doesn't want to be alone.
My company or someone else's would make no difference.
So I finally,
so I find it all very insulting to my intelligence that she's trying to make me
think this is a connection only we share.
Um,
I made it clear I'm not going into the show anyways.
I've shared this with my friends and apparently that is widespread.
I just find it as getting out of control and a fee when a female in our lives
that is not in our family expects to be treated with the same considerations as
a romantic connection in which we obviously have to do shit we really don't want
to do.
All right.
Okay.
I see what you're saying here,
but I think,
um,
part of her probably wants to hook up with you.
So that's probably why she was feeling rejected a little bit.
Um,
but what I would do in that thing,
but now,
you know,
I'm really not feeling that,
but listen,
I know this cool bar,
you know,
up the street.
Maybe we can go do this,
blah,
blah blah.
See how that feels up.
Uh,
I dunno.
Maybe it did that.
I Dunno.
But yeah,
that would be annoying.
You know,
if she wanted to go fucking see it.
I Dunno.
I Dunno how to,
I don't know how to,
uh,
how to answer this one here.
Think I'm on a fucking
missed the boat on this one.
Dude,
you shouldn't have to go to,
you know,
look at,
what you got to do.
I'll tell you,
if you guys want to see a great example of how to fucking handle women,
I swear to God,
watch the Jersey Shore.
Okay.
I know you're rolling your eyes right now.
And as much as people are laughing at that kid who's like,
you know,
it takes me 25 minutes to do my hair.
Oh my God,
I said not to touch it.
And then you touched it.
Oh,
that fucking dude who has the Travis Barker Cadillac Tattoo.
Um,
that fucking dude,
if you watch the episode was sneaky,
gets blasted in the face.
That dude understands exactly how to hook up with women and how not to get into
a fucking relationship.
And then also how not to give a fuck if they get mad.
He,
I'm telling you like I'm looking at that guy going,
this fucking guy possesses the knowledge of women that I,
it took me 41 years to figure out and he knows that 20 and he's in his peak
physical conditions.
Guys are fucking,
you'd get kids my hero when that dude,
uh,
the situation,
I was going to say,
the suggestion when he fucking comes back with the two girls,
right?
And one of them's a mass in the other one's hot and he's a fucking wing man for
forum.
He's hanging in there and he's hanging in there and then it gets to the point
where the other,
where the situation's not gonna Hook Up.
He taps out and he said,
he goes,
look,
you know the deal.
You meet him,
you bring him back,
give him a drink,
get him in the hot tub and then hook up with them.
You know,
that's the deal.
If you can't fucking do it,
I'm out.
And he just was totally fucking,
I'm telling you,
he has,
he has it down.
So what you got to do with this girls,
something like that is the girls coming around,
she's saying,
I want to go see this band.
Just don't ever get upset and just be a look.
I'm,
I'm not fucking into it.
And then walk away and don't even let it like consume your life to the point we
actually go out and you talk to your friends about it because you just wasted
energy should be out there talking to some other girl.
Hey,
go fuck that girl.
Fuck her and fuck fucker fucking concert.
You did the right God damn thing.
Um,
by the way,
let me get to the questions for this week as somebody,
I might as well do that because this will actually make it flow a little more
cause somebody,
uh,
um,
somebody said,
okay,
bill,
I want to know your thoughts on the prick that deck Snookie at the end of last
week's episode.
But uh,
I also have to get your take on Mike Aka the situation and his buddies attempts
to get laid hilarious.
Uh,
dude,
his buddy is getting all the fucking ass on the planet.
Mike,
the situation,
I dunno,
he,
he's not a closer and he's really good at getting the appointments,
but he's not a fucking closer and uh,
he's,
he's like,
he wants to be the other dude,
but he's not the other dude.
He's got it down.
If every time he goes out the club he's making out with some girl,
he's grabbing her fucking tased,
that bringing girls back.
They see them on the street.
That guy,
I'm telling you,
the guy is a fucking,
you know,
I had fun.
I don't even think I have gained like that now.
Even if I could go back when all this shit I know now.
If I went back I wouldn't be as good.
That fucking kid.
He's the shit that kids,
Shit Mike,
this situation,
that situation Mike is,
you can't close the fucking deal.
And as far as the dude who punched deck Snookie Eh,
that was,
it was brutal.
I know.
I made fun of that girl with the legs sweep.
She fell down.
She was like,
oh my God.
It was funny.
That girl Snooky was like,
was sobbing.
I felt horrible.
I felt really bad for her.
And that guy is a fucking animal who,
um,
they should treat them like a pit bull.
They should,
you know,
pit bull bites somebody to take him down the fucking street and they put them
out of his misery.
That's what they should do with that guy.
They should take them.
They should literally take them to an animal shelter to not even a place for
humans and just,
you know,
lay him on the table,
have a muzzle on his face.
I like how we tried to,
I forget the guy's name,
but like say whatever his name is,
Mike Johnson or something.
He's like,
you know,
that's not the way I was raised.
What you saw in that video is not the real Mike Johnson.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
That is you.
That is you and you're drunk.
I'm sorry.
That's you.
That's a,
that's a part of you.
You fucking asshole.
I like those people.
They try to blame the alcohol.
Like if they say something racist or they fucking blast some girl in the face
and then try it.
That's not the real me.
You know,
I got this problem.
I drink alcohol and I become this different per fuck you now.
You doubt your doubt.
You know a drunk man's words are a sober man's thoughts.
It's one of the greatest fucking quotes ever.
You don't become somebody else.
You know,
maybe your,
your,
you have a shorter fucking temper,
but there's no fucking way that guys never punched a girl in the face ever.
He wasn't even that drunk.
It wasn't like he was falling down drunk.
I think when she called him ugly,
I think that really touched in on some,
uh,
childhood shit because the dude is ugly and you know,
he lifted a bunch of weights trying to be like,
no,
don't look at the face.
Look down here.
This looks good.
Right?
I think she tapped in on some shit.
Um,
but that was the classic situation of a woman just not feeling like she's ever
going to get hit because I would never stand up on a bar stool.
I mean,
talk about a horrible way to begin to fight.
I'm going to stand up on a bar stool with my feet,
you know,
instead of,
that little thing.
So your feet don't dangle,
you know that part of the bar stool.
She was standing on that and then she leans over and I'm gonna lead with my
chin.
Hey,
you ugly motherfucker.
You know,
ah,
terrible move on her part.
He just fucking,
it was a straight left fire.
If I remember correctly,
you guys ever watched when we were at King's and Ali was hitting a George
Foreman with the straight right.
The one punch.
He wasn't ready for it.
He was doing it as a south paw.
Oh Man.
He,
yeah,
that was,
that was like a loose some fillings that was like blunt.
I thought it was horrible.
I didn't think it was funny at all.
And uh,
that guy should be prosecuted to the full extent of the law and uh,
he shouldn't put the guy down,
but you know,
she's doing,
he should have him out in the backyard,
you know,
like you do with those dogs where you have them on that wire and you have the
leash attached to it,
you know,
and then ugly girls,
I'm not ugly girls.
Girls should be yelling over the fence telling them how they ugly and you know,
your mother fucker then is he runs the lease just fucking yanks his neck and his
feet go flying out from underneath him.
He should do that for a month.
Um,
yeah.
So there you go.
All right,
next question bill.
I just started listening to your podcast and it was one,
oh,
this is a great question.
I was wondering if you ever look at a funeral procession,
if you have a look at funeral processions,
um,
I try and catch in the cars that don't care about the dead guy in front of them,
in the hearse and notice that the car,
uh,
and try to notice that car full of people laughing.
Do you ever do this?
And when are you coming back to the Boston area?
Uh,
well I'm just booking my 2010 now,
so I'll be coming back next year at some point.
Um,
absolutely.
I always do that.
There's always a,
uh,
um,
what is that
morbid curiosity to try to figure out which car has the people who were directly
related who gives the fuck the most?
Yeah.
And,
and as a funeral procession goes down and down and down and down,
it starts becoming third cousins.
As someone who worked with the guy back in the 60s.
Yeah.
By the time you get to the back.
There's like people watching DVDs in the head rests,
you know,
drinking Margaritas.
I definitely do that shit.
Um,
and I'm glad you asked that question cause I really thought I was the only
fucking person who doesn't.
Um,
all right,
I got to wrap up this podcast here.
It's going to be a little quick.
People just,
no,
it isn't 46 minutes in.
Look at me.
Look at fucking me.
Let me read a couple of things here.
Here's a kisser quote I read.
Somebody said to me about the press,
listen to this shit is a little conspiracy kind of shit.
Uh,
John Swinton,
the former chief of staff for the New York Times was asked to give a toast to
the independent press before the New York Press Club.
Um,
and it's obvious that he believed that the comps concept of an independent press
was a farce that he no longer wished to be a party to the following is reported
to be a quote from is monumentally revealing toast.
Um,
all right,
so this is basically a reported quote.
No one can even confirm this.
Got To love the Internet.
This is what the guy says about the independent press.
Uh,
there is no such thing at this state of the world's history in America,
uh,
of an independent press.
You know it.
And I know there is not one of you who dares to write your honest opinions.
And if you did,
you know beforehand that it would never appear in print.
I am paid weekly for keeping my honest opinion out of the pie out of the paper.
Others of you are paid similar salaries of similar things for similar things.
And any of you who would be so foolish as to write your own,
he's honest.
Opinions would be out on the streets looking for another job.
If I was,
if,
if I allowed my honest opinions to appear in one issue of the paper before 24
hours,
my occupation would be gone.
The business of journalism is to destroy the truth,
to lie outright,
to pervert,
to vilify,
to fun,
and at the feet of Mammon,
I don't know what the fuck that means.
And to sell this country and his race for his daily bread.
You know,
at nine,
knowing what folly this is,
toasting to an into print independent press are the tools and vassal of rich
people are rich men.
I what that was supposed to say,
vessel behind the scenes,
we are jumping jacks.
They pull the strings and we dance our talents.
Our possibilities in our lives are all the property of other men.
We are intellectual prostitutes.
You know,
can't you just see Michael Douglas giving that speech in one final effort to win
an Oscar in some melodramatic movie that Oprah would fucking recommend?
You have to see this movie.
It's so important.
Excuse me,
I'm going to eat another glazed pork chop.
Um,
all right.
That might that I think it might be the podcast this week.
I'm trying to get to one other thing here.
Once again,
I want to thank everybody who came out to my special.
I'm so fucking proud of it.
Um,
I really,
really think I got a good one.
And um,
I'm trying to chill out.
I'm chilling out.
I'm actually taking a vacation here until January 15th.
That's how fucking lawn I'm off.
I went to stubhub.
I got my Rosebowl tickets,
me and Joe Barton Nica going again this year.
I got a little place out here where I know I can get a couple of,
you know what a couple of Stovies of the a Desi Arnaz variety,
if you know what I mean.
And uh,
you know,
the ducks first the bucks,
we're going to go see that shit.
I'm actually toying with maybe going to the bcs game,
but they want so much fucking money,
but uh,
it's right up the fucking street.
How do you not go?
So a,
you should be asking yourself,
Bill,
what are you gonna be doing during the break?
Absolutely fucking nothing.
Can I get over this cough?
I'm going to try to work out a little bit.
And,
uh,
I've been playing my guitar.
I have a new guitar hero,
uh,
Duane Allman.
You know,
I used to listen to the almond brothers and shit when it came on the radio.
And I used to work in the warehouses back in the day,
but I didn't have an appreciation to what I was listening to.
And Duane Allman and Dickey Betts have become,
uh,
like I am downloading everything they've ever been on.
And uh,
and now totally fascinated with the fact that Duane almond used to,
it sounds like he would just show up at studios in play on other people's albums
and not even be credited.
So they actually saying like,
you don't even really know,
you know,
how much work that the guy did.
I don't know.
He just fucking seemed like he loved playing.
You know what's amazing about Duane Allman and as you look at the guy,
he looks like he's fucking 37 years old.
I don't know what it was about people back in the day.
They just looked old,
you know?
I mean it probably doesn't do it.
That's the guy from truth and salvage company.
That's the fucking beard mustache.
She has,
I was saying,
you lyses s grant,
it's via Duane Allman.
It's that fucking Elvis Presley mutton shop thing.
And right as it goes to your Chin where it'd be this big Grizzly Adam Beard,
you just hook it right up.
It makes a u turn right around your mouth.
Like,
it's,
it's then going to go around and go back up.
You same cheekbone,
but it doesn't,
it go,
it's like almost like it pulls into the gas station underneath your nose and
then goes right back up.
He goes right up to your other ear.
Um,
I was with someone yesterday.
I went to go,
I went to go buy that live at the Fillmore east album,
uh,
on record and uh,
and I was going to look at it,
look at that guy.
That's Dwayne Omega.
How old do you think he is?
And he's like,
I don't know,
mid thirties.
And I'm like,
the guy died it fucking 24.
I think maybe he was almost 25.
But uh,
anyways,
there's a clip actually on youtube if you want to see you look up the almond
brothers.
I can't remember the uh,
oh wait a minute.
I hang on a second.
I got to get you,
I've got to get you this.
There's one with,
they play on the tonight show where it's still Johnny Carson and you want to
talk about unbelievable musicians first of all,
the tonight show band with doc cybereason's in all of those guy,
unbelievable players.
So they come out and the almond brothers play one of their,
you know,
they have blues rock things.
Absolutely rip it up and then you know,
they play for like five minutes.
And then when they'd done Johnny's like,
all right,
we're going to do something.
A little different.
Docs going to come out and play with the band.
Then they did like this tribute to Charley Parker.
Like there's jazz thing and they just stay one right there with doc and all
those.
All the fucking tonight show guys.
It was,
it was unbelievable.
So I'm just look up the almond brothers tonight show.
Fuck.
Sorry.
But if you're not into that and you want to watch bill Graham yell at somebody.
I got,
I got to bring this up for you.
I'm sorry man.
Hang on a second.
It's a,
you just search,
uh,
Fillmore last days.
Let me see if I can find it.
Here you go.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Just search
Fillmore.
The last days,
search this and me and my girlfriend always make fun of how like hippies talked
in the 60s the way they said,
man,
they say it was almost like m y a n like,
hey me and not trying to get hassled me in.
So basically this,
this fucking video,
it's Bill Graham getting ready to do the last show at the Fillmore West,
the one down on market street.
And he decided that he was going to have all just San Francisco bands and a,
so this guy comes in,
he's a member of this band that doesn't get to be put on the bill and he's upset
with Bill Graham and he's,
he's trying to get on the fucking show and Bill Graham won't put them on and
they ended up having this fucking argument.
Let me see if I can get to it here.
Of course they're not going to show it.
And he's just like,
you know,
man,
it's like,
I can dig it man.
It's just like,
you know,
I mean,
we're selling more tickets than they are man.
And it's just like,
you know,
I mean,
it's just like far out me and,
and it ends up escalating to the point and Bill Graham's being like totally
legitimate.
He goes,
well,
you should just respect that I'm being honest with you,
man to man.
And it escalates to the point where Bill Graham is not budging and this guy has
no other argument and he makes the worst fucking decision he can make,
which is basically tells bill Graham to go fuck himself.
Not knowing that Bill Graham evidently had a big time temper,
had fought in Korea and is an absolute psycho.
Um,
if you just want to watch bill Graham chase a hippy out of the Fillmore West,
you got to watch this thing.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
it's a little bit long.
If you're not into the beginning,
just skip to it.
You'll see it's a guy comes in,
he's wearing like the rob Helford leather hat.
Uh,
but anyways,
that is it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Merry Christmas to everybody.
Happy Kwanzaa.
Happy Hanukkah.
Happy New Year.
Happy fucking end to 2009.
I hope you guys all have a happy and safe holiday.
I will talk to you next Monday.
And once again,
thanks to everybody at the Fillmore,
thanks to the crew.
Thanks to Molly at the punchline.
Uh,
Jeff wills,
eye everybody,
everybody who made it,
the whole fucking thing happen.
Arts and industry,
everybody,
the management,
parents and everything.
I feel like I'm accepted an Oscar,
but I feel like I won one because it went that great.
So that's it.
Everybody have a great week and I will talk to you next Monday.
[inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible].